it's the best action buffet yet in the
mandalorian chapter six which also fills
in just a touch more of mandos
mysterious backstory after the events of
Chapter five on Tatooine mando is still
desperate for cash and in that
desperation by itself almost more than
he could chew on a prison break mission
he is definitely the honorable man Quinn
suggests he is but that doesn't mean he
can't engage in a touch of
double-crossing to keep himself alive in
the episodes final moments we realize
that mando took the Republic distress
signal from the prison ship after
turning it off to give himself all the
time in the world to lock up his
would-be mercenary teammates and escape
and secret it into Quinn's belt to draw
Republic fighters back to the mercenary
base and destroy the rest of the lot
he's playing to win because if he loses
it's his life and the child's that will
be lost his clever escape has put him in
the best position he's been at since the
start of the series his ship is working
baby Yoda is safe he has money and with
all that comes a lot more options for
him to stay on the run and effectively
hidden we are entering the end game of
this first season however so rather than
feeling encouraged we're more inclined
to worry about how far and fast the fall
will be before the climax of the finale
for now let's drill into the
illuminating bits of chapter 6 juicy
details about mandos youth this episode
fills in some of the wide blank space
that previously existed in mandos
background before chapter 6 we knew he
was an orphan and that in the present
era he was a card-carrying bounty
hunters guild member until he snagged
baby Yoda out from under his clients we
had no reason to believe he was anything
other than the honorbound but morally
great gunslinger weeper saw him as any
orphan will have had a rough childhood
and maybe even a rebellious phase of
their youth but it seems young mando was
quite the violent outlier it's difficult
to reconcile the sad single dad we've
come to know with the Mandalorian this
assortment of reckless murderers once
knew in chapter 4 when manda was asked
why he adheres so strictly to the
Mandalorian Way of life and never
removes his helmets he says he wants to
honor the people who have given him a
life to live we've been presented with a
whole new side of that life in Chapter
six and it seems there was a time when
mando did not respect those gifts at all
and use them for his own ego and vanity
mercenary commander rands er ran MalK
recounts mandos general attitude in
their previous partnership when the
young Mandalorian apparently referred to
the grittiest and most the illegal
mercenary work as
get practice Shion also suggests mando
is growing soft when she learns a baby
Yoda's presence on the ship man mando
tries to play him off as a pet thank you
for the type when released from his
prison cell quinn comments that the man
who left him behind has suddenly
reappeared as a savior just what type
did mando used to be it makes sense an
orphan is recruited from a very young
age into a warrior society trained in
various methods of lethal martial arts
and graduates out into the galaxy with
no personal attachments we know mando
hates droids as a result of whatever
part of the Clone Wars he lost his
family to and any young man orphaned by
violence could understandably grow up
very angry and when given the ability to
show off as a badass pounced upon it to
fill that void in his life the deeper
question yet to be answered however is
what exactly happened to change mandos
outlook and reorient himself correctly
within the Mandalorians warrior ideal as
a controlled merciful and honorable man
when did he stop using his gifts for
murder get out from under an illegal
mercenary squad and join a guild
whatever it was and whenever it happened
it's stuck because mando spends this
entire episode trying to work around his
teammates bloodthirsty impulses by the
end of the episode mando frankly has
every reason in the galaxy to kill each
one of them for the sake of his own
safety and the safety of baby Yoda not
to mention how completely they have
betrayed his miniscule amount of trust
he chooses not to off them because he's
a better gentler and more emotionally
centered man than he used to be we can't
shake the feeling that this seems more
and more to be the very thing that will
undermine him as his past continues to
catch up with him in this vicious
backwater corner of the galaxy the point
of this series is not to tell us how
cool Mandalorians are a point to this
series is to tell us how kind and good
this Mandalorian tries to be despite the
world he lives in check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about the Mandalorian are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]